JOHAN PELGRIM: So
welcome back.
In this lesson, we're going to
start the process of signing
the user in.
Now, the first thing we need to
do to prepare the sign-in
process is manage our GPPSignIn
shared singleton instance.
This is something that is a
singleton, and you can access
it from any class and before
you use it to sign the user
in, you'll want to set a
few properties with it.
Now, there are a number of
places you could do this.
Your app delegate might be a
good place because you can
make sure that everything
is set before
anything else is loaded.
However, just to keep our code
a little simpler, I think we
can do this in our Intro
ViewController as well.
So I'm going to do this here.
Once we're in our
ViewController, the first
thing we're going to want
to do is import the
Google+/Google+ header.
This will include everything
we need to access sign in.
So next I'm going to create a
method called, let's call it
InitializeGPPSignIn.
And this is where we're going
to access that shared
singleton instance and set up
all the properties for it.
Now the first we're going to
want to do is create a string
that references our client ID.
So InAString, gameclientid.
And this is that string that I
told you to copy and paste a
couple lessons ago.
But I also told you that if you
didn't copy and paste it
like I didn't, you can go back
to a Google Play Developer
Console and grab it.
So I'm going to do that.
Let's go to Chrome here.
And under
play.google.com/app/publish,
I'm going to click
the little game
controller icon on the left.
There's Guess My Number
under Linked Apps.
Again, I can view the iOS linked
app, and here's my
OAuth to client ID.
So I'll just copy and paste
this and put it in here.
And let me fix the typo here.
There we go.
This kind of feels like maybe
something that I'll eventually
want to pull into a constants
file or something somewhere.
But I suppose this is
good enough for now.
I'm feeling a little lazy.
Next, let's grab our
sign-in object.
So we'll just reference this as
a local variable, sign in,
and this equals--
we'll get that from
the GPPSignIn--
SharedInstance singleton
method.
So this will grab our Google+
sign-in object that we can
then set various
properties on.
So for instance, I can do
signin.clientid equals our
gameclientid.
We're also going to want
to set the scopes.
Remember that these are the
special powers that our valet
key has that gives it access
to certain things in the
user's account.
So for this, signin.scopes
equals, and this is an array.
So we'll call NSArray
array with objects.
And we want HTTPS://www.goog
leapis.com/ot/games.
And yes, I do realize we should
probably make this a
constant somewhere in our
library, and we'll leave it
like this even though we're
only including one object.
I still like to use the plural
array with objects method
because at some point
we'll probably be
asking for more scopes.
We also need to set
our language.
And this we can usually get by
going to NSLocale, preferred
languages, object and index 0.
We want to set our
delegate to self.
And this is basically telling
our sign-in object where it's
going to report that the user
has finished signing in.
And finally, sign
in should fetch
GoogleUserID will be yes.
What this does is it tells the
Google sign-in object that we
are going to need
the user's ID.
You'll recall back in our
earlier presentation when we
got our access token back from
the system, we then used that
to make another call saying, OK,
now that I have this OAuth
token, who is this user,
and the system will
return the user ID.
This is essentially a shortcut
saying, hey, OAuth2 library,
since this is something that we
request fairly often, why
don't you just go ahead
and make a call.
We'll get the user's ID as soon
as they've authorized our
application.
This is kind of nice, and it
turns out this is also
required by the game service.
It's going to need user ID, and
it's going to grab it from
the sign-in object.
So you probably haven't used
this setting before, but it
required to get game
services working.
Now you'll notice that at this
point we're getting a warning,
and this is because we've set
sign-in delegate to self, but
Xcode is telling us, hey wait
a minute, this class is in a
GPPSignIn delegate, so
we can fix that.
So up here at the top of our
ViewController.m file next to
this interface line, we're going
to say that this class
conforms to the GPP delegate.
At this point we get another
warning saying well, OK, you
said that it conforms to the
GPPSignIn delegate protocol,
but you haven't implemented this
required finish with Auth
error method, which is required
in this GPPSignIn
delegate protocol.
So we can do that as well.
So we'll add finish
with auth error.
And basically, this is the call
that our sign-in object
is going to make.
It's part of the delegate
protocol.
That says, hey, the user
is finished signing in.
Hopefully, there is an Auth
object attached to it, and if
not, here's an error object that
explains what went wrong.
So for right now, let's
just print something
out to our log file.
So NSlog, I am finished
with Auth.
Auth is this object, and error
is this, and we'll add our
auth and error objects so that
hopefully, we get something
interesting in the
debug output.
So now we can run this, and
nothing interesting happens.
m that's because I
didn't actually
sign the user in anywhere.
We've initialized our GPP
sign-in object, but then we
haven't actually done
anything with it.
Luckily this is an easy fix, and
we'll tackle that in our
next lesson.